so before I got Turtles I mean she's a  little too young to know exactly what's  going on before I got Turtles he her  grandfather clay on my wife's side of  the family got her to like  custom-designed turtle dolls which he  now plays with so she's gonna be here in  a couple of weeks and I'm actually  really excited for her to see the guys  just as the turtles fun but you know by  the time the movie comes out next a year  from now she'll be two and a half and  hopefully she'll get it a little bit  more you see cowabunga to her all time  I've been saying cowbug all day know I  do know I do a I say doodlee doodlee did  it say dude I go I wanted to and I  wanted to do and I wanted to and I  doodly-doo and I tickler Oh